huit smoked salmon all year round but at
Christmastime would consume it by the
bucket loads now they're normally rides
like this beauty packaged beauty slides
and all looking nice and trim but it
doesn't start out this way much of the
smoked salmon we buy in supermarkets
it's sliced by machine but at Foreman
and son they insist on the traditional
way hand slicing the best quality smoked
salmon is sliced by experts like Darren
Matson it's hard to just even imagine
how many slices I've done but I probably
failed the whole of rim with one slice
of smoked salmon Darren has been slicing
salmon for 25 years and he's so quick he
looks like he's working in fast-forward
he's the best in the business I'm the
count world record holder I've done it
in one minute and 34 I'm not ready for
that Darren's form of hand slicing is
called a D cut sliced like this creates
a digital texture and it guarantees each
slice looks and tastes great it also
ensures the maximum number of slices
as a chef I'm intrigued by Darren's
technique and you're not cutting all the
way through not kind of the way focus at
this stage I've never seen that being
done like that before so keeping it on
keep it on the scheme
you must think at weekends me um I so
hope yes now so then what we got to do
now we got flipping it up like that
it's a shaking around a little bit swap
over okay so left handed I could look to
slice down there but then it could if
it's all good for you it's best to
really slice the way you're comfortable
with and we work on that one I keep it
flat towards you yeah and then first one
here you want to come as down as as far
as you can further yet further down then
each time coming back up yep a little
bit further out so I'll play like that
and pull yeah it's back down yeah so you
just lift it right away up yeah and then
just drop do like your right hands
that's it yes they're nothing like not
only London's come out there have a nope
so that's where you want to be the final
part of the method is to sweep the knife
underneath in one move which takes off
the unwanted skin turnover note that's
right that's it
that's incredible just about the bottom
there just come down more than other
than either of you you gained it there
you corrected that there sure so apart
from that I think you yeah bit more
patches you know I think we're gonna be
gonna have it what I mean bit more
practice a bit more speed I'm pretty
good with a knife so I think with a bit
more time I could actually give down a
run for his money in a world record
challenge